oh hello good evening I'm Christina
welcome to my home that is my youngest
daughter Shaina and my niece fire aah
and my oldest daughter Sylvia is it your
loss this is the living room where we
sit together in the evening or on the
weekend
mice mmm but my family doesn't only
consist of women I have two men two
little men as well laughs no Rafi ID ID
is there we named him Haiti he was
living on the street and that is where
we found him yes thank yo he's been with
us for a week one crazy thing about me
is that I love to collect spirits and
liqueurs I don't drink them I just
collect them I have bottles from all
over the world aqui this is lemon
liqueur from Mozambique fake pickens
it's bottled here what's that I was
instantly this is a souvenir Champlain
we had three bottles of champagne on her
honeymoon we drank two and this is the
third whatever cool this elf we're no
longer together but perhaps my daughter
will open the bottle at her wedding
pelvis who knows because I meant the
delegates up
you
I here TT these are Zulu pod berries a
fruit from maputo by soonish wash cycle
make your dainty you can suck on them
and make juice with them thank you hyung
Milania and this is the fruit of the
bulb AB tree akela Sandra and Jeffrey
garnish sorry usually we make juice with
it or add it to yogurt mousse all kinds
of sweet things